(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] All right, everybody.
We have reached the end of the hour,
but we have time for one more story.
This is what I'm liking.
(short upbeat musical flourish)
(audience clapping)
If you're a wrestling fan,
tomorrow kicks off the
biggest event of the year.
It's WrestleMania 39
at SoFi Stadium right here in Los Angeles.
You can stream all the
action exclusively on Peacock
and this year promises to be wild y'all.
I am fortunate to have two of the biggest
WWE superstars dialed-in right now.
Everybody say hello to Bianca
Belair and Cody Rhodes.
What's up y'all?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Bianca] Hello.
- [Cody] Hello everybody.
- [Kelly] What's up y'all?
Well, Bianca, I'm gonna start with you.
It's good to see you.
And last time we spoke,
you were about to make
history at WrestleMania 37.
So what's in store this year?
- You know, the last time
I saw you, WrestleMania 37
I got to the Main Event at WrestleMania,
and I walked out the
SmackDown Women's Champion.
So I'm very excited about
WrestleMania 39 this year in LA.
I'll be facing Asuka and defending
my Raw Women's Championship.
So I'm hoping to walk out still
you're Raw Women's Champion
at WrestleMania this year.
- Yeah. All right.
(audience cheering and clapping)
And Cody, this is a big
deal for you, right?
'Cause you're coming off
a major injury, right?
- Yeah, actually, upon my return to WWE,
I was hanging around for a few months,
having some great matches, and then I,
I tore this pec tendon
totally off the bone.
It was down in here.
They tied it back on over
here, said nine months.
I was able to come back in seven
and win the Royal Rumble,
punch my ticket to WrestleMania.
Get the opportunity to
wrestle Roman Reigns,
our undisputed champion
to win a championship
I've never touched, nor
anybody in my family,
has ever touched.
So this is uh, this is the big one.
- Oh I love it. Man,
congratulations on healing well,
by the way.
You're like I did it in seven.
(chuckling and snapping)
(audience clapping and cheering)
Like, um so Bianca, after WrestleMania,
you have another big project coming up
so tell us what it is.
- I do.
My husband and I are actually getting
a reality series on Hulu.
We're very excited about it.
We're gonna pull the
curtain back a little bit.
Everyone gets to see
who we are in the ring.
And so we're really just
gonna show, you know
our home life and our support system
with our family and
pull the curtain behind
and kind of get to see who
we are outside the ring.
And we're just, we're just
excited to share that part
of our life with everyone.
So make sure everybody
watches and, and tune into it.
We need the ratings.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Kelly] I'm so excited for y'all.
Congratulations on that.
(Kelly clapping)
Remember everybody this weekend,
April 1st and 2nd,
WrestleMania goes Hollywood
at SoFi Stadium in Los Angeles.
You can catch all the action
exclusively on Peacock.
Thank you so much, Bianca.
Thank you Cody, for joining us.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
(audience clapping)
All right, so now is the point,
we usually give our guests $1000,
thanks to our season-long
partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the Go-To Erasable Pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But, today they're doing all right.
They don't need it.
It's going to someone in the audience.
So check under your chairs.
There's a taped check
under someone's chair.
(drum roll drumming)
(crowd murmuring)
♪ Who's got it? ♪
It's taped up under there.
(audience member exclaiming)
(Kelly high-pitch screaming)
(drum and band music flourish)
(audience clapping and screaming)
- [Kelly] Girl!
It took you too long to find that check.
- [Daisy] Oh my goodness.
- [Kelly] Are you like that at Christmas?
Like, well I guess I'll open
it like, it's like (laughing)
(audience laughing)
What's your name? Where are you from?
- Um, I'm Daisy and I'm
from Houston, Texas.
- Yes!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Kelly] Well, welcome to
California fellow Texan.
How do you think you're
gonna spend the money?
- (exhaling) I don't
know. I hate to say it.
Oh, I'm, I'm a beginning
photographer, so a camera.
- Oh that's incredible!
(audience clapping and cheering)
(Kelly clapping)
- [Kelly] That's such a,
that's such a cool thing!
I love that your photographer.
Well buy a fancy camera.
- [Daisy] Yes.
- [Kelly] All right.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] You're welcome.
- [Audience Members] Woo!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- All right. Thank you to
all our guests this hour,
Kevin Bacon, Kyra Sedgwick,
John Owen Lowe,
(audience clapping and cheering)
Jessica, Nia, Jared.
I hope y'all keep enjoying
this mad mad mad March,
and may you all win your brackets.
Like I won't. (laughing)
Have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.
(audience cheering and clapping)